oui la question que vous posez c'est
a-t-on les moyens et moi je suis désolé
c'est pas et en vrai en vrai ce qu' dit
BR le c'est plus c'était plus une
attaque politique par rapport à Mar qui
lui dit c'est à cause de Vladimir
Poutine qui attaqué
l'raine HUG c'est
insortablee c'est moi qui donne la
parole tu commences à me saler ou je VO
bien
disouésol une phrase écoute non mais
siux si tu veux finir tes phrases tu
finis chez
toi tu laisses finir et ben c'est ce
qu'on va faire moi je réponds clairement
à votre question a-t-on les moyens non
non si jamais on augmente l'électricité
de 10 % qui va ruiner des Français les
mettre dans un désert énergétique dans
un malêre profond on n pas les moyens
d'aider l'Ukraine si on n pas capable de
garder un prix de l'énergie correct pour
les Français je suis désolé obligé les
aider on est obligé c'est ça on n pas le
choix on a le choix on pas le choix ça
c'est la morale non mais on pas le choix
la morale bien entendu qu'il faut les
aider mais les moyens qu'on y met je
suis désolé si aujourd'hui le
gouvernement et Bruno Lemer l'a dit si
la dette explose si on n' pas d'argent
peut-être qu'il faut réorienter nos
priorités et peut-être que notre
priorité c'est de garder un prix de
l'électricité qui fait que les gens vont
pouvoir se chauffer C et ben je pense
que notre soutien militaire exponentiel
tant français qu'européen à l'Ukraine on
peut peut-être se poser la question
peut-être que les armements César qu'on
envoie cré beaucoup d'emplois rich j'ai
pas fini ma phrase je dis à un moment
s'il faut faire un choix moi je me
demande et j'ai évolué je me demande
s'il faut pas choisir les Français qui
peuvent plus chauffer contre l'armement
fourni aux Ukrainiens je suis désolé
alors justement parce que j'a
j'aimeraisir j'aurai des oui après mais
les oui on sait ce que vous allez dire
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi non Daniel
ben c'est exactement ça vous vous
souvenez tous ces boulangers qu'on a
reçu qui fermait qui avait les larmes au
yeux je suis désolé le bouclier sans
bouclier tarifaire on va avoir à nouve
si on veut on va voir défiler des
boulangers donc voilà et je comprends ce
que tu dis Hugo évidemment et puis c'est
mais quand en 2014 la Russie a attaqué
la crmé ça n'a pas changé notre vie
quotidienne donc pour l'instant il y a
des urgences et l'urgence c'est c'est
voilà c'est que les boulangers ne
ferment pas les uns après les autres
parce que un boulanger qui ferme c'est
un village aussi qui qui qui meurt à
petit feu donc voilà il y a des urgences
malheureusement c'est comme pour les
sans abris c'est comme question vous
poser est-ce que est-ce que l'Ukraine
n'a pas bon dos et est-ce que l'Ukraine
n'est pas un
prétexte d'acc bien
sûr par chaque fois un moment à chaque
fois qu'il y avait un problème on disait
ouais mais c'est l'Europe c'est l'Union
européenne maintenant dès qu'il y a un
problème en France c'est à cause de
l'Ukraine parce que
commraine toute la naivé quand on a
parlé de quoi qu'il en coûte les gens
ils étaient contents ils étaient chez
eux on est payer le Président il l'avait
dit quoi qu'il en coûte je parlais avec
certaines personnes c'est bon on est
payé chez nous on fait rien on va pas
travailler tu crois qu'ils vont pas
récupérer leur argent un jour tu crois
vraiment qu'ils vont te faire des
cadeaux comme ça des milliards comme ça
gratuitement tu les verras l'argent
récup aujourd'hui il récupè avec une TVA
sur les produits qui ont augmenté et des
produits essentiels aux gens qui veulent
se nourrir il récupèent une TVA
là-dessus c'est scandaleux ils récupèent
une TVA sur sur l'essence qui a augmenté
c'est scandaleux ils vont récupérer une
TVA sur l'électricité c'est scandaleux
faites le replay c'esten royale quand
elle est venu elle nous a expliqué qu'il
y avait pas besoin d'augmenter
l'électricité elle elle nous l'a
expliqué là faites le replay vous allez
voir donc tout ça le quoi qu'il en coûte
les gens naïfes qu' on dit bah c'est pas
grave vous inquiétez pas on est rester
chez nous on a rien foutu et ça va bien
se passer bah non ça se passe mal
g des agriculteurs tu as vu ce qui se
passe chez moi maintenant à il y a des
des priorités et la France l' donc les
gens voilà je voudrais juste voir le
sondage après je voudrais qu'on continue
pour voir un petit peu ce que disent les
les téléspectateurs ah B c'est fou
incroyable la
France de voir ça c'est incroyable de
voir ce chiffre ça rejoint un petit peu
ce que disait Daniel et G Verz oui r
mais c'est à cause de Bruno l justement
que les gens répondent comme ça le maire
mais la faute sur l'Ukraine ça faitî
toutes les tèes conspirationistes la
problématique c'est le marché commun
l'Espagne en est sorti réc pourquoi sort
pas c'est ça qu'on aimerait tu nous
racontes la vraie question qu' faut se
poser Bruno la question qu'on peut poser
à Bruno le mer si demain on arrête de
soutenir l'Ukraine est-ce que ça va
changer la vie des Français non c'est
des décision commun poser question bravo
est-ce que si demain on arr éidment
évidemment ça ne changera ça ne changera
pas et c'est pour ça que c'est
catastrophique de dire que c'est notre
aide à l'Ukraine parce que ça donne env
dit tout à fait
pas puisque on n nous a dit moi je suis
con comme
une quand on
attaqu dit normal qu'on P l'électricité
plus ch c'est normal que les boulangers
font faillite que les factures augmenté
c'est à cause de la guerre en
raineé c'était normal quand les prix
avaient effectivement augmenté sur le
marché comm maintenant les prix sont au
même niveau que le que qu'avant la
guerre donc là l'raine bond donc ça ch
la présidente de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie c'est Madame
vargon c'est pas une révolutionnaire
elle a été ministre longtemps elle a dit
le prix du gaz baisse on a de l'éolien
le prix le vrai prix aujourd'hui elle
avait suggéré - 0,3 % c'est clair c'est
théorique c'est technique et Bruno le il
dit plus 10 % donc c'est de la politique
c'est parce que effectivement il le dit
lui-même je veux sortir du quoi qu'il en
coûte on est quasiment ruiné la dette
explose et on met ça sur le dos de
l'Ukraine du rassemblement national on
fait de la politique mais il y a un vrai
problème d'argent et on fait payer aux
Français une imprudence qu'on a eu
pendant des années donc ça ça ne va pas
impossible il a raison g en a 3000
milliards de dettes et le quoi qu'il en
coûte c'est 240 milliards donc forcément
on est complètement detté et forcément
on doit rembourser effectivement ce qui
est insupportable pour les Français
c'est que les prix de de gros baissent
et pourtant la facture elle explosent
donc il a un truc qui est vraiment pas
logique mais pour autant moi je suis un
peu sur la ligne de de Hugo et de et de
Valérie en fait ok l'Ukraine donc on
fait rien on nide pas on regarde
distrêtement avec un œil un petit peu
ailleurs ok ils envahissent l'Ukraine
s'ils envah sils envahissent la Pologne
est-ce qu'on fait quelque chose s'ils
envahissent un bout de l'Allemagne
est-ce qu'on fait quelque chose et alors
après donc je regardeis juste pour que
vous sachiez parce que on croit qu'on
est que l'Ukraine par exemple la France
aide 19 pays prioritaires dans sa
politique de développement il donne
1liard 177 millions au Sénégal 107
millions d'euros au Mali 100 millions au
Burkina assut 92 millions au Niger des
millions aussi à la Palestine à Gaza et
c'est très bien et moi je trouve que
c'est très important et donc voilà on n'
pas les moyens mais aussi il faut qu'on
ait les moyens pour ça et je pense qu'on
ne doit pas ne pas aider tous ces
pays-là je pense je pense sans vouloir
euh montants rien à voir quand vous
dites 100 millions pour un pays et je le
dis ça a l'air d'être des montants
énormes
c'estériso je suis F que la
France P
ptant alors en 2024 nous serons le deè
contributeur européen 1,3
milliard non mais non mais non mais
juste ce que je voulais vous dire
Géraldine c'est que voilà vous me parlez
de 100 millions et ceera c'est très bien
et moi je penseil faut aider tout le
monde oui mais non mais oui mais non
c'est c'est pas c'est pas le problème
mais là l'Ukraine c'est 1 mliard 3
1liard 300 million c'estàdire que c'est
13 fois plus mais c'est pas de l'argent
c'est des c'est des armes en fait en
fait la manière dont on calcule les
sommes qui sont donné à l'Ukraine c'est
sur c'est par exemple si on donne un
char on on part du principe que nous on
va devoir aacheter un char 80000 € et
c'est la valeur de rachat futur qui est
qui sert de base au calcul total du don
qu'on fait à l'raine et les char c'est
des emplois
je lis je lis une réaction vous n dites
ce que vous en pensez vous répondez à
cette personne les Français n'ont pas
payé une situation dont ils ne sont pas
responsables à chaque fois on nous
demande encore des efforts ce n'est
jamais la faute de l'État stop
maintenant euh voilà donc qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça moi je réponds qu'il
a on n pas à payé si on pouvait aller
défendre tout le monde et que on nous
dit à nous ça nous changera pas
grand-chose on va pouvoir rester
raisonnable au niveau du gazélectricité
de la bouffe de l'essence allons-y
soyons patriotes allons aider faites
comme fait les alliés il y a pas de
problème sauf que là ça nous impacte
beaucoup trop à nous et les Français tu
vas tu vas leur demander dans la rue que
est-ce que tu es content d'allerer
l'Ukraine il va dire moi je suis
découvert tu vois bien ça n plus aucun
rapport plusun rapport avecraine mtenant
ou il faut le dire pour qu'il arrête de
dire
ça prud sur a tout à fait résumé
monsieur anoun l'Ukraine AB Bono nous on
crève on se cache derrière l'raine pour
dire ça aurait été plus courageux de la
part de Monsieur Bruno Le Maire de dire
voilà le quoi qu'il en coûte on est en
plein dedans on a merdé on vous on a
même pas merdé on vous a aidé quand il y
avait le covid on vous il le dit par
ailleurs d'ailleurs il dit parurs parle
pas de parle pas de il pas dit là mais
il dit le quoi qu'il en coûte
voilà moi qui est pas
très si tu me dit que ça augmenté à
cause de l'Ukraine et que la guerre va
être finie en 6 mois Poutine il sera
chassé et tout rentrera dans l'ordre
faites un effort souvenez-vous faites un
effort c'est 5 6 mois après on
verraix gr j'ai regardé cet après-midi
le prix de gros il on est on est à Mo-
57 % par rapport à l'année dernière et
personne n moié
Mo on est privilégié regardez bien la
nourriture nous on est des privilégé
regardez bien vous vous moquez de moi
quand je vous dis 1 kilo de Gruère 8 €
regardez bien les 10 cachés 13 €
regardez bien maintenant regardez bien
quand on dit on est passé à 57 alors on
dit qu'on va aller à plus 10 marché
aussi de beaucoup de baril il faut dire
que la France produit assez
d'électricité pour se fournir et en vant
même à l'étranger ça il faut que vous le
sachiez et il faut quand même dire que
la France n'est pas le pays où
l'électricité est la plus chère en
Europe sachezle puisque il y a pire il y
a en Italie il y a
euh le problème c'est ce système
d'indexation le problème c'est cette
solidarité européenne et un prix médian
il y a un prix médian et donc on paye
nous un prix qui est en dessous du prix
réel c'est pour ça que on est dopé qu'on
doit payer plus cher mais là où il y a
malhonnêteté Cyril c'est que 57 % on
aurait dû en principe on devrait cette
année payer la moitié de ce qu'on a payé
l'année dernière et ça n et ça ne sera
pas le cas et donc en fait c'est ce que
disait Gill ils ont besoin de récupérer
les 6 milliards dont ils nous ont fait
cadeau avec le bouclier tarifaire ils
vont les récupérer parce que
effectivement la France n'a plus les
moyens mais moi je voudrais juste qu'on
n'ppose pas l'Ukraine en fait parce que
je suis aussi d'accord avec ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure si on laisse faire
Poutine demain ce sera la Pologne
l'Allemagne et peut-être pourquoi pas la
France oui je veux dire donc il faut
aussi se rendre compte de ça et être
solidaire vis-à-vis des autres peuples
européens mais on devrait aussi revenir
à un prix normal a Lolo qui te dit tu
vas lui répondre comme ça c'est bien moi
j'aime bien répondre téléspectateur Lolo
qui dit désolé Géraldine maillet arrête
ta propagande nous n'avons pas eu de de
l'Ukraine nous avons pas eu de l'Ukraine
si la France ne s'était pas occupée de
la guerre entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
nous nen serions pas ainsi on périt le
gaz moins cher VO même moins qu'avant
donc est'est-ce que tu réponds à cette
personne c'est comment impossible j'ai
pas de propagande ni voilà je je suis
pas dans l'idéologie je donne des faits
donc voilà je je moi je pense que c'est
évidemment je comprends que ce soit
inaudible pour les téléspectateurs qui
sont dans la précarité qui ont du mal à
à terminer leur mois qui ont du mal à
bouffer à remplir le cadit je comprends
que ce soit inodible mais je pense que
l'Ukraine est une sorte de bouque
émissaire un peu idéal aujourd'hui et je
pense qu'on a pas le choix aujourd'hui
ou alors à ce moment-là on dit écoutez
la France c'est c'est on va plus au
conseil de de sécurité de l'ONU on se
lave les mains on n plus aligné sur les
États-Unis on n plus aligné avec
l'Angleterre on s'occupe plus de rien du
tout et voilà et je pense que peut-être
que la donne va changer quand il y aura
Trump si Trump revient peut-être qu'à ce
momentl il voudra autre chose lui comme
position par rapport les États-Unis
souffrent autant que nous avec
l'électricité l'essence les produits
Mar marché
comm moi j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête de
prendre des exemples d'autres pays qui
ça fonctionne bien chez eux ils sont
autonomes ils payent leur essence moins
cher que nous leurs produits moins cher
que nous ils ont moins de taxes que
nous
ou mais il font pasigner les
tax on dépend de qui pour leab
saite encore il prodous ilot plein de
produit à nous les États-Unis il
attendent pas après nous ils en on rien
à il tu parles américains ils
savent même pas qui est le président en
France donc un moment donné c'est moi je
veux bien être gentil avec tout le monde
je veux bien aider tout le monde la
derre j'ai demandé un Américain qui
était le président français ce m'a
répondu Jordan de
lux ah ouais quand même oui non mais moi
ce qui m'énerve dans les propos de Bruno
Lemer pour y revenir c'est que on est
face à une bombe sociale et pour ne pas
être confronté à ça il met ça sur le dos
du RN il met ça sur le dos de la Russie
alors que je suis désolé il y a les
agriculteurs qui crèvent de faim qui
sont en train d'exploser il y a les
étudiants qui mangent pas il y a toutes
les catégories sociales qui sont
impactées et ce ce ce fléo social si on
dit oui c'est de la faute des autres on
le on le règlera jamais et ça c'est
impossible ça va exploser C il y a une
question Hugo Hugo est parti non il est
là tu peux dire bien là voilà si on me
donne l'autorisation de parler j'ouvre
la
bouche il faut que tu lèves la main bah
oui mais depuis tout à l'heure tout le
monde parle il lève pas la main je
su il y a des échanges qui se font entre
comme ça tu me les montreras tu vas voir
ils vont sortir et tu sais mon chéri si
tu tiens pas ton plateau tu sais tu vis
te dire tu sais ce que c'est tu fais les
scores de Bertrand chamerois donc voilà
donc je te dis écoute-moi mon chéri une
balle perdue voilà à cause de
toi tu vois voilà c'est c'est mon
Ukraine à moi celui-ci voilà hein voilà